everybody welcome to Monday man hey
how's it going we're here today with
Michelle Moore oh oh a lot of coffee
welcome Michelle and it's December so
we've dressed up in our finest holiday
now you can tell us a little bit about
this before we get into this freaking
monstrosity that steals the show steals
it ruins it steals it or ruins it oh
okay fair enough
steals it Andrew This Is It this is a
Doctor Who poncho I loved it it's like
it's got the the weeping angels that
look like snow angels an amazing
Cyberman at the bud unbelievable I love
they made all these horrific enemies I
know it's amazing
topic that's where I get most of my
t-shirts around the world
that's right now this looks like maybe
the cat threw up yeah I'm wearing a cat
vomit with I got the little bells here
this came from tipsy elves calm in case
you want to look like a complete a hole
with your family like the balls are
really out shining the blue you know
what's weird is there's also balls on
the back so it's like when I lean back
it's just like I'm like sitting with you
pong balls it's just like the most
uncomfortable but it looks great like a
furry mocap I know exactly exactly this
is you just want to steal it if you
don't want to talk to your family if you
don't your family to talk to you wear
this don't be like oh my god this guy's
I'm drunk no exactly so today we're
playing Star Wars Battlefront it's very
exciting
you've only played this one time before
time id3 and I played it last or
Saturday or something but your Star Wars
fans of course who is in a Star Wars
face isn't by now
Alec hat says bleh the crazy cat lady
yeah that's exactly what I am yep the
balsa yeah it's Shady the peck is their
boss they do this is yeah this is what
the cat coughed up we there we go
finally this is how it finally happens
exactly exactly
I know the only problem would be you
know the issue would be if I went out
drinking in a sweater and like half when
we're missing and then I would probably
cause like I would eaten them or
something I'm like two days later I look
in the toilet okay anyway I like to
class it up here we're gonna play Star
Wars Battlefront okay and let's start
with some missions all right now is
spoiler alert I'm terrible at this game
and just die like all it's all the time
I it's just I and I'm gonna be dying in
this so all right so what do you have
you fight have you played any of these I
played Tatooine okay um I feel like we
should go to Endor let's go to Endor man
let's do it
let's do it oh you know what we have to
do is master wait no do it should we
know let's start with your start with
normal let's start with norm can always
ramp up yeah online or local co-op local
let's do local exactly oh there we go
continue we don't care all right sorry
that's me so I'm sorry do it again thank
you guys
Vlad I'm sorry do that again dude oh you
did it she did it wait now I have to do
this now you do that now I do this now
you teamwork Michelle what are you up to
these days
tell the man tell the people where they
could see you well right now Michelle
Mauro and everything with one L know
that's right also I have a card right
here they told me that but I didn't
remember us I didn't look at the car
though to be fair I did look at the card
I remembered from five minutes ago
really that's good I think of credit
credit is due to pretty sure with you
why all right I have a stream right
after this on geek and sundry every
Monday there we go
so and we're giving away a valve game
key today what so you can essentially
say you own half life 3 if it ever came
out you're giving people pre halfway
because you get past present future and
all valve games like that's awesome oh
my god so tune in to win whatever
absolutely geek and sundry every Monday
yeah all right I'm up top here okay so
you're black and I'm not Conan yeah
you're not Conan which is technically
true it's fair waiting a waiting partner
Blaire
like how it calls his partners finally
pitching the balls and now we're
partners
where's best holiday sweaters is
oblivious yeah it's on the inside that's
gross
Beth did hurt her leg though tell
everybody what happened to your legs so
we can mock you during the stream what
were you doing was also like I really
don't know what is soul/psyche besides
something that sounds like hell on earth
why would you do this and you paid for
this right [ __ ] idiot
what is your problem seriously awesome
yeah this is great now I have allergies
so the real Endor would be bad for me
oh yeah there's probably ragweed this
looks like ragweed right here I mean and
doors are alien planet but I'm just
saying look there's definitely pollen
here or some kind of it there's some
kind of yeah maybe some poison ivy
exactly oh here we go
alright so left trigger left rigors like
your scope in and then you have the star
cards right which you can use your
different powers yeah so basically a
triangle of god oh I see
triangle give you a powerup I think the
l1 is the bow caster and r1 is an ion
torpedo which which is only good against
like only good against light like ships
a TST here's a question sure do you say
do you say 8080 or DJ yeah at it who
says atm all we said in this kid in this
game they said what did you guys say
because like I always had a - yeah in
here oh man big cream shooters in the
house way I give you a bell and come to
your assistance when needed
Thanks picture that's the nicest thing
anyone's ever said to me I get hey girl
I give you a bell and come to your
assistance when needed that's so
specific
very generous shock trooper sir I just
shot that guy in it oh I love the [ __ ]
shot damn it I will say it so this
there's no ammo there's just a cool down
page yeah overwatch oh you know yeah
absolutely wait what are your are your
first-person [ __ ] in your own world
World of Warcraft I play everything but
everything but I'm not like I don't love
FPS as much as I love third-person sort
of stuff so and trap warmers but like
for FPS I loved like if it's an RPG so
like Borderlands yeah yeah like father
father I don't know I'll be honest it's
yeah this is very I would hope you would
only be honest this is that yeah I'm not
gonna lie to you this you can lie to me
sometimes I find it um I'm not a fan of
fallout no why not I think it's really
boring
I like the other fallouts this one I've
just this one is quarantine yes the
story's a capella the only it's a good
story I feel yeah I mean oh did you
already get the yeah I was missing my
Liam Neeson I'll give you that Oh
casters kind of fun I know that's the
thing about Endor is it's really old
barbed oh wow look at all these
stormtrooper bodies oh my gosh now I
have a question I've heard that there's
gonna be female stormtroopers in the new
movie how is it possible if they're all
Jango Fett clothes I'm not really quite
sure I've been kind of hoping the movie
no that's the only thing it just gets
into a really deep discussion about an
existential discussion about souls and
like what did that that's in the movie
just like I think people in this they
have female stormtrooper voices in this
game because that's awesome my good
friend Marisa Rae is a female
stormtrooper Oh
oh my god that's awesome super rad I
love that that's crazy that I would love
to be part of the Star Wars universe in
any way right even in this sweater even
in this sweat especially in that if JJ
was like hey we need you to come but you
have to bring your cat Bobbitt
follow sweater maybe
like half alpha when what time I'll be
there you know what one thing really
struck me
I mean I'll get him what's up like
besides the lasers from these
stormtroopers when I start playing this
game it was really interesting I didn't
realize how visceral the sounds were the
sound design is really great in this
game and loose the Star Wars sounds like
the lasers and the TIE fighters and
stuff it's it's like ingrained in my DNA
and when I was a kid yeah right it's
what one of the greatest things that I
you know like you feel like an instant
what was okay oh wait Edward says a dad
is acronym like ASAP so a dad should be
correct although people send us tend to
say ASAP as a word for some time now
interesting 18:18 like somebody got all
snobby you need to change look at I feel
like if I walk across this log it's like
dirty dancing yeah wait what were you
about to say before I cut you off you
guys we're like dirty dancing right now
Oh third person up on the oh wait we're
being shot we're trying to dad I don't
know if you could shoot you can't shoot
and do that I think in this but I think
when you do single-player you can I
can't shoot it like don't feel whirring
whirring were you here we were on the
log together bleh I know and I fell off
the log I'm not a good log partner I've
always said that you know that Michelle
I'm aware but I was hoping that you
would change your boy Oh God out of all
the Star Wars movies all of them well
the mainland yes not like the ancillary
stuff yeah not the way even the first
the [ __ ] was what's your favorite
Star Wars movie oh I mean I'm a sucker
for the original just cuz it's such a
good it's cheesy it's great I love it
but you know Empire is great ice cream
Empire I think would be number one if it
didn't end the way it ended I don't like
movies generally
that we're you know another movie is
coming up cuz it makes me feel like look
the movie should stand on its own even
if it's the second series it should
stand on its own as like oh that was a
great wrap up yeah but like they're just
standing there at the end and they're
like you got six robot hand they're all
kind of like oh something Crazy's gonna
happen to us later in the next movie you
know I'm afraid of a cliffhanger but
it's got to wrap up the story in a nice
way what are they on what about you what
about you favorite movie I loved Empire
as well but I think as a child when I
hear he first watch it yeah obviously
Return of the Jedi
oh yeah huge because Ewoks he walks and
that was just the way it was when I was
a kid exactly ah you can't how do you
put nice how you punch the question of
Jesus oh my god alright I am torpedoes I
really cuz the Ewoks like cuz they are
so cute I needed up getting a cat that
looked like an Ewok I was obsessed oh my
god really yeah
cat away a cap with an Ewok not a capo
what did you say a cat oh it's gonna say
capita that's not obsessed if you just
buy a hat that didn't you walk you're
like no I was so obsessed that I had to
do that I had to get a hat where I need
to come save you nice right you know no
you don't need biology owner oh you know
you stick you might need the apps it's
like that's like it ad out with a lisp
extra life very good do it up
okay where you hear yours all word you
love that part I like your voice in that
thank you
it's very good I've always been good at
my act boring as I call it
I am torpedo in your face
alright so wait we both have the same
alternates yeah guns as we go got it
yeah you can yeah you can get oh my god
there's so many ways yeah there's 15
there so that's like 12 more waves that
I'm ready for oh my god can anyone do
star wars voices I got act barred down
can you do any Star Wars voices I do a
good Princess Leia hi I love you hon and
then you want to do Han do you know Han
he said she says I love you and he says
I know oh that's good for a second I
thought Harrison Ford was here and then
I was like oh it's you I look at these
dicks not in the movie by the way
stormtroopers are jetpacks I reject it
maybe don't be Joe no Easter Egg in the
game wouldn't that be awesome oh my god
that'd be awesome you guys were just
joining us we're here with Michelle
Moore oh hi guys
oh right after this is gonna have a
stream I geek and sundry where they're
giving away of alkie
and why is it why is it called a valve
key I don't get it okay because it's
really special because it'll open up the
valve library to all of their games past
present future that are valves that's
also yeah like you hear like
counter-strike and past present and
future yeah in future why that's the
whole thing that's bananas wait for how
long how long is the future forever
that's crazy yeah and so like the world
explodes is there like okay I said can i
buy one of those how much is the price
like a billion dollars like one of these
weird that's awesome you know oh there's
these guys that guy
that's kind of good yeah I will say do
you ever hear the story about Mark Cuban
where as soon as he sold whatever Hager
made his original money he the first
thing you did was call up American
Airlines oh my god and he was like hey
how much money could I pay you to like
just get four free airline tickets for
the rest of my life
what yeah and so he has like some crazy
card or some deal work out with him
where forever he can just go on American
Airlines whatever you want be nice to be
a billion I know but that's really smart
on his part though that is but like
that's you're saying that's a valve key
that's a Cuban situation exactly give me
the Mark Cuban of video games yeah is
exactly cute not even Mark Cuban has a
valve Cutie Mark Cuban I don't think has
about he doesn't even know what video
games are he's never played a video game
I think though he has because remember
just recently he came down and did the
whole mic drop oh yeah that's right
that's right that was awesome I Colin
Cowherd you suck yeah called him out and
which was awesome because it was great
the event that they're kind of that
Colin got all like tripped out about on
ESPN was the heroes that the Dharma vent
that I hosted earlier this year on ESPN
that's awesome he freaked out and he's
like video games aren't real sports he
says like anybody actually made me do
this I'd kill myself he was like he was
actually saying suicide that's crazy
I know so people were coming down on him
obviously Bob's as I like to say in the
sweater
ABB's am I gonna be a bigger a hole wait
that guy's gonna shoot up in this damn
see the force field is what gives it
away
yeah wait I know I think if you get if
you get their jet pack
oh yeah the Nick no I mean if you shoot
their jet pack they'll kind of like fly
around and hit a tree
[Music]
and how do I damn it Sonny too many we
have to pseudo cubic cubic what do you
think about my ladybug is that true okay
let's start that as a thing if you count
my balls it's how much good luck I have
for the holidays all right let's go you
want to play let's play no no oh I mean
we can do you mad all right let's do it
you're gonna kill me though you're gonna
kill me you're gonna kill her we're
gonna suggest they're gonna kill me I
was gonna say then we'll play a giant
battle wait how do we do not survival
missions how do we do battles wait but
then we can see each other that's true
we can see each other but still that'll
you know whatever I don't know the maps
I know the wife's maps well in know a
little apps or I know the maps or the
posi wops where do you want to play huh
you wanna play I call it host it's a
little bit dirty yeah it's when I've
been at the club I like to act real hosi
I'm gonna do it ladies let's go ladies
you want to get hosi with me I want a
hundred and ten percent doubt it
hey magic man what's up good to see you
Baldy don't you even start Michelle of
Spritle shoes wait what's the purple
cheese thing asked ya people asked we
need to know so I'm not if you want to
plan hosts first pizza okay we're
playing on hoes not a fan of pizza go on
shut up it's hope oh wait so purple
cheese go on because when that's weird
pizza gets like that and has purple
cheese and it's like translucent E and
it's creepy and I don't like eating it
wait what weird pizza yeah I don't know
I like to eat pizza without cheese
okay heats up and it gets all like which
means more pizza for all of you so don't
get all mad and hate on me
just means you can eat more pizza wait a
second I don't like it you like pizza so
what's your pizza look like just sauce
no cheese no cheese it just sucks yeah
and then like mushrooms and olives and
tomatoes okay cool
second question is it not is it seeing
the cheese that upsets you what if we
made a Scituate oh it's both so I see
these we highly when you like go and put
it back yeah and then you take it out
like any pizza ever on earth is looked
like this to me I will say Chicago has
Chicago purple cheese Chicago has a
style of a pizza where it's like real
thick and the cheese like inside the
sauce is on top Beth you know I'm
talking about somebody who's from
Chicago to me rebels are galactic or I
call it go lock goal of what I can't go
lock when you're rebels are you wanting
to be or you want to be galactic no I
know you can go back hit hit the old
circle hit build circle I kinda wanna be
alright Palpatine II the bad guy are you
gonna be palace I wanna be Scott he's
hot so low is hot by the way he's super
hot what kind of taste buds you got girl
it's not the taste though she says she's
Mark Hamill is up the game Awards the
other night oh my god you think they're
keeper Sutherland I'm like oh my -
childhood crushes just chilling lost
boys and wait I tried to get into the
game before it's after party anyway now
so yeah so you can do so here there we
friends right no we're enemies so you
can do so you have minions so if you
press the trigger you shoot the
lightning okay uh l1 does like a special
like a kill shot light like a power
lightning right the top button leaves
power ups and then r1 I'm sorry
triangles pirates r1 you do this crazy
scary like fly at somebody how does the
the l1 go though
like hold it down it goes oh no you l1
l1 the top boom yeah like that it's like
a also you know if you pretty l3 if you
pressing the stick does like runs you
know it leaves like a powerup which is
kind of that's alright this is awesome
alright oh you gotta go the other way
return to come back I'm going to your
map your map over there just exploring
it was no big deal
it's fine in this way it's way against
watches you know just taking a look just
taking a peek yeah just scenic route
taking a peek Palpatine he just wants to
see some stuff in his life do you think
Luke is gonna be evil in the new movies
I guess it kind of feels like that from
the trailer I mean they wouldn't do that
to us right you know like they wouldn't
do that to us but that's true yeah and
yeah I must say like his dad was Darth
Vader but his sister's that's Joe
chilling sister maybe his sister is evil
cuz you know this [ __ ] I'm getting you
in the back
you already said yeah this if
oh my god your lightening is killing me
[Music]
no can't block your stuff with my yes
thing then I fell off the thing no you
have to return to combat
yeah too bad your grandmother she didn't
tell him that
yeah exactly oh my god because is it
here's the thing light in this with the
Sith isn't there always two right
there's like the master in the
apprentice very true and we only know
kylo Ren is I'm just saying master can
be live happen hey your what's up you
think he's gonna be evil its I mean I'm
just putting it out there
I put all so Hamlet hasn't been doing
any like he hasn't been doing a lot of
press they're kind of keeping more for
this very true they have I mean he
showed up for the game awards great by
the way the Joker he's awesome I think
great that he can just be the Shocker
and the Joker self awesome like one of
our greatest here is an awesome of them
yeah
wars most terrible villains by are you
your conv fan yeah best batman villain
coming at you I'm coming here I come
coming at you I'm just hacking through
your oh can I pull I can't block can I
block your step
I can't kind of yeah feel it come to the
dark side
oh my gosh got you right in the dick
yeah right and right and they grab the
lightsaber right in the Palpatine Hamill
also has an epic beard grow yeah Hamels
got a serious beer that's awesome he
does he didn't even look like he looks
maybe like an evil Skywalker perhaps
[Music]
now what would how would he become evil
fully what are all the theories he would
give into his passion give into his
passions him just giving in something
would have to happen you're right you
wouldn't just give it maybe they kill
his dog like Inchon wish they'd kill it
and they can't they kill his uh his
space dog is that possible oh my god the
skirt killing chili fowl Beth do you
like have you seen Star Wars does Beth
like Star Wars oh you are when are you
Michelle when you seeing Star Wars come
back here hey ho ah you have dudes with
the bags of jetpacks ya know corn heavy
gunner best Batman Miller's the shark
they got sprayed with shark repellent
the sixties movie Weezer I think you
mean the bat shot the bat shark
repellent that's my favorite line he
goes quick Robin hand me the bat shark
repellent we don't need to put that in
front of everything what the hell man
everything has to be backwards yeah best
Batman villain penguins great why do you
like the Penguins wouldn't it be so
awesome by the way if it's always sunny
universe in Batman universe was the same
universe so like Frank like starts you
know like Adso yeah and then one of his
weird like whatever one of his weird
things ends up like
let's call McElhaney and and those guys
Charlie Day that would be so funny yeah
so here we go
so there's stuff where we can't see oh
okay
so we can do so with these big missions
the way are with these big things we're
gonna play online we're gonna trade off
every time we die okay so you take this
you take this you start and then so
you'll get power-ups different power-ups
and some of the power-ups randomly will
be turned into a hero okay okay and then
you just be calm somebody else Skywalker
or Palpatine or something which is here
awesome oh yeah yeah well no yeah so
what you eat so we can play I mean I
guess you have you can play heroes vs
villains where you heroes vs villains is
yeah let's do that one that's so this is
round based combat so basically it's
three heroes versus three villains right
okay and all right so we're gonna be
rebels and and you need to defeat the
other three guys so it's really kind of
it's it's six on six you're playing six
on six basically okay and you're trying
to kill the villains alright hey joy joy
what's up ooh
Pedro just bought this game today it's
awesome this game is so so fun yeah how
long you been playing since it came out
oh yeah yeah thank you rob this is a
draft not everyone says my album drops
no one says pick it up that's what it's
about
but yes since it drops that's what I've
been doing and I can't you know what now
that I know I'm in control I'm just
feeling my own balls which is good so
you're gonna be a normal guy so you're
you'll have a ion torpedo which you fire
against ships which I don't think are
going to be in this round and then the
r1 is your is your grenade which is
pretty fun and that dad that also has a
cool-down period self so are ones my
grenade and ones your ion torpedo which
you're not gonna not gonna yeah yeah
that's apps and then every round and
your I think it's like first two five
rounds wins so you're playing like two
minutes why don't you just play this
entire you play the entire thing I'll
just talk abuse either way I'll just
talk and be Steve exactly flaws org okay
closet wat to two sevens got the game -
here we go and start or you can also
yeah there we go we're gods of whole but
Sanders dead Vader's dead these are two
minute rounds though you to me routes go
that way cuz i underneath the ship two
minute rounds up said who can we can we
start a bring back boba fett campaign
you know what's interesting is
everyone's obsessed with Boba Fett why
is that I think it's because like Star
Wars has done a great job
I love world-building Star Wars has done
a great job of building this whole world
just showing you pieces of stuff and not
like you know really going on and on
about it so you get this sense of like a
much larger universe which said they've
expanded upon oh my god which they've
expanded on and like all the other all
the other you know in comic books and
all this other stuff but I think the
reason why people have both that is
because you don't see a lot of him it's
mysterious he's a mysterious character
small asian boy malaysian boy exactly
he's all the way up there I'm Brooke
running around a medium transport and
hunt Caravan and killing people why not
you're right zigzag one go check that
Sarlacc pet I think Boba Fett's stuck in
there too
well you know in the comics Boba Fett
doesn't get killed by the star like he
crawls out so then he continues his his
is Mandalorian super super Mandalorian
what kind of before it's like a super
Mandalorian or something wind force
still of Boba Fett after that kill next
round here we'll try it off yeah yeah
people do have this kind of like
obsession with what's what makes a sexy
Boba Fett what's a sexy Boba Fett
weightless armor okay like cosplayers
sure less armor no pants basically
there's me Boba Fett sexy both of bettas
pants or no-pants dance off pants off I
just feel like that is oh Jesus that's
his way of just relaxing yeah sure Boba
Fett would be way to never take his
helmet off justice man yeah Bubba Fett
will be wait Bubba Fett Boba Fett public
that would be way less intimidating if
you just had sweat man yeah man how did
you get Leah I just it's random in this
random Palpatine
decadence oh yeah that's me at the club
in this sweater like I obviously not a
fan of the Dib I know you had killed
baselines just the last year oh damn it
I screwed up I should just run away it's
okay
boba fett takes over as leader of the
Mandalorians at some point in the book I
don't know what a min DeLorean is it's
not like a wookie Mandalorian exactly
paint blob 352 what's up the I'm in
stock I'm in stock mode at all times I
just I'm so Palpatine II in real life
Michele could attest to this we were at
comic-con oh my god right on way I was
yeah I see you could be on oh yeah so
net we can also be honor guard in fact
yeah it comes up you just have a heavier
gun and get particularly the small asian
boy is on fire terrible thing to say out
of context okay
ps4 you to geeks yes proud geeks
Mandalorian is Boba Fett's people oh
okay I get it
kind of like how Han Solo is a cow
whistle right it sounds so low-calorie
nerds that's what we are tired Ewok is
group a group of mercenaries lots of
clans Mandalorians are all mercenaries
oh I didn't die oh I'm so yeah I was I'm
so Palpatine II suppose I got you maybe
a drink
Oh Palpatine II would be a great you
have to drink it like
oh I'm Skywalker here we go yeah we're
gonna get this a [ __ ] now let's go I'm
[ __ ] in yeah my robot hand oh yeah
absolutely
only for a certain amount of time oh it
has like a deflect cool yeah you got you
there's a force push thing which is cool
let's get into it where are these
a-holes I since I have a robot hand I
can give someone a mega finger just like
a super you're saying han Solo is Jesus
Palpatine though in Star Wars turns
there's like the lore of Star Wars is
unbelievable to me it is so huge it's
bad
crazy yeah it's awesome it's been going
on forever see I love those sound listen
to that ladies oh good I think it's like
the original movies word we're still
kind of scary in a way yeah totally like
that we were used to and then the I
think the prequels were like giving such
velvet gloves that I mean it yeah weird
sorry great hoping this goes finds that
middle ground
like again I agree yeah the first three
that was you know it's weird like I've
never heard somebody say that but that
totally hits it on the head like it
totally was they were way to keep Z yeah
they're big and bright and you don't
really want that now like Empire is
pretty dark it starts with like like in
dark in like the ice caves like crazy
yeah you're right it's very scary in the
eighties were scary though I mean even
like the neverending story
yeah yeah I mean it was and you need
that danger I think that like really
make things great so yeah so if you
press l1 and r1 you'll be able to set up
like a Wow
no respect yeah yeah yeah you can be
honor guard there and protect the
protector execute order 66 ICU code 420
to say yes for you to any charge are
fairly not too fat to play Empire yeah
wind forces empires the definition of
what a sequel supposed to be I totally
agree Empire was great murdered
alright I think it's time to get out in
the big bad world and do a giant you can
we can play did you guys say jakku jakku
boy or something we're from the new
movie which is a DLC I think it came out
today
the Heartless to the Heartless jus
that's such a nice thing for the first
day of Lulu Fon says lapland labyrinth
was oh my god you remember the once what
the one scene where I'm like it's the
like where she gets like the hoarder
thing and you're kind of there that
totally freaked me out is she had all
her stuff and I remember just going it's
just stuff yeah yeah and that was
terrifying terrifying that's I mention
hurt his being
lost in the labyrinth forever exactly
and her baby brother's missing go home
all those movies were scary the crystal
was scary oh my god Dark Crystal is
crazy all of them Hey Joe up what's up
miss cherry boom
oh the dlcs tomorrow the dlc tomorrow
today is Jack you out EA I'll get upset
if we streaming we're not supposed to
that's a bad thing go the main game then
yes all right so you know what but still
let's play that turning point let's play
walk
let's play some Walker assault oh this
is great this is super fun yeah what is
this so this is the game here is if
you're on the Empire side you're trying
to protect the walkers and you the
walkers until they get to their thing
and destroy everything if you're on the
intro the rep yes if you're on the rebel
side we're on the rebel side so we have
to stop the walk no no no we're gonna
trade off luck we'll be fine
and trust me I'm gonna die all the time
yeah I literally am just trying to get
to the point where I get half the kills
that I get like it's I'm at like eight
in like 19 in terms of like kills and
deaths so okay Oh clawzord said it
actually did come out today for me
alright so we'll play John go after this
okay perfect perfect I came out early if
you pre-ordered okay good good good
who is she I'm Michelle morrow somewhere
you can find her at Michelle tomorrow
with one L on everything yeah you got
your twitter at Michelle Moore
you've got Instagram you've got Facebook
Facebook's Michelle Murrow official
there we go
yeah there's somewhere official Google+
how many circles are we in now
Friendster Michelle Moore Oh people
could see where can people see you you
can see her on the kiddies yeah it's
under a stream right after this right
after this give me a way of Balqis which
would be awesome and then regularly are
you on every month at yeah every Monday
should come on I will I'd love to what
about whisk in the sweater each time you
want if I promise if I promise to wear
it two of these sweaters two of them at
one time
exactly yeah I'll wear like a double you
know I'll figure like like a two-face
thing well cut because tipsy elves sent
us this sweater and a bunch of other
great sweaters
I may I might make that's a great great
tipsy elves calm Thank You tipsy elves
there we go all right so you're trying
to you're trying to get through the up
links and activate them so the why
bombers can come in and hit the a dots
and it's a dat's all right guys oh yeah
this is gonna be my new tinder profile
pic just be like don't forget
LiveJournal oh yeah I'm on tinder I'm on
a hinge in bumble bumble is no bumble is
tinder except the girls you can't talk
to the girl so like why if we match
I can't message you first you have to
message Kieffer's why is that I think
it's cuz guys are horrible creeps guys
are the worst gender there is out of two
genders we're number two when it comes
to gender and so I think it's it's to
protect oh yeah I wasn't kidding by the
way I'm so bad at this I'm so bad okay
it is a dad thank you we force windforce
do that picture for tinder shady says I
couldn't well can you get less matches
than zero is that possible I get
negative matches okay yeah why clearly
right it's princess lip a she's a
princess she's loyal B she's the leader
of the you know one of the main people
in the rebellion I'm a rebellious person
look at your sweater your hybrid values
look at us I killed by yourself at least
I haven't done that yet all right here
we go let's go
I follow the image I like how we have
unlimited ammo you take fall damage yep
Oh TV I was trying to hit him with the
ions or P times week and I really it's
gonna be a lot tried third person
Garrick said it's easier okay let's try
a third person up on the defense there
we go
oh but you know what I guess it doesn't
it doesn't keep us yeah it doesn't keep
us in third person good question I they
should do a TLC with you class is over
back to lab work bye everyone bye see
you dr. Benway you have to fight off Han
Solo in a Wookiee that's some serious
backup Leia has that's true Chewbacca's
dad and you're right um you know what's
kind of weird I will say so if you if
you do l1 and r1 it'll do an automatic
it'll put down a turret that will
automatically kill infantry yeah
also your powerup doesn't go away when
you die really so you what you still
happen yes oh yeah so if you get killed
immediately you can put the turret also
for the hero power-ups and the vehicle
power-ups and that happens you it you
would have a time limit of 12 seconds so
you need to kind of do it handle so you
need yeah hold down our hold down L so
you can only fire that at vehicles yeah
and you hold you hold down left trigger
and it'll be like yeah y2 and y3
impressions are Admiral Ackbar hello
everyone that was terrible
Leia and the ion torpedo
those are my three impressions that's a
good one I'll hold down the touchpad
somebody says first of all video game
voice thank you yeah I was in grete
to the grand theft auto's were you one
of them I was orbital strike incoming oh
god no no I don't have the power I would
oh Jesus there it is oh god get out of
the way boom he dead I on one of them I
think it's grant that San Andreas I'm on
the radio annually and in Grand Theft
Auto
not the last one but the one before that
I'm a quarter of all the joggers slash
personal trainers that's great so then
when that game came out why I got about
a tree I don't know I got about 50
pictures of dead characters my friends
like to to book killed you nailed you
like just dead people they just would
find me and just kill me that's great
yes miss cherry boom you killed me a lot
in GTA I was not a prostitute in GTA
that's real life on the prostitute or a
hope as I like to call oh yeah you can't
shoot it until the chill goes out it'll
say attack the atoms oh it's late tachy
88 you know not to those guys you can
kill everybody else is shooting all
right look this sounds are so great no
see this is getting me excited to see
Star Wars oh man I've only seen the pimp
down there in the left oh really that's
how you've seen yeah because I've been
trying to save myself CPT ps4 YouTube
yeah I'm trying to do that because I
know you're fine okay
yeah they have your money they have your
money that's me too
alright shoot it shoot it shoot it you
can use your I hold hold ELQ old L hold
l2 or out hit out one hold l2 l2 l2 l2
no this one this one there we go and
then for our our ll one everybody
whatever right trigger write your column
[ __ ] oh God i sandbag you sorry Beth
uses the sword to talk we're so close
we're dying so it was really good that
we were both weird but yeah he's holding
on the left yeah exactly
oh good get that truth right orbital
strike l1 Noel - no r1 yeah Carolyn
chill evolve maybe you can get play to
teach you I can't teach anybody anything
it's terrible right right the colors
this this is I will say this is my least
favorite board because it's it's too
hard it's just all create oh yeah I can
get on a speeder it's just too crazy
it's hard to see things and it's howth
is great I'm gonna keep saying it until
it catches on we keep saying forever so
people say ho I don't care people are
exactly exactly
bring yeah hey rocket punch go good to
see you but yeah I feel the same way
about most movies I want to see like I
wanna see Creed I only saw the first of
the ice you know like and seen those
Star Wars I did somebody tricked me into
watching the second teaser trailer which
is fine cuz JJ's good about not giving
things away
oh Jesus Oh oh my god that guy was
coming in real hot nothing happened you
know they've got that armor that plant
that heavy plastic crotch armor a lot
like David Bowie laughs I love it
big [ __ ] when I was a kid I wanted to be
able to do the crystal ball thing
and then and then I found out it wasn't
Bowie's hands I mean I was a kid and
that was enough
no it was somebody else yeah I felt
cheated don't you feel cheated
I'm sorry did I just ruin your childhood
Derek but in a good way scary like you
weren't at scared get it oh come on he's
got a jet pack
my nephew who's like seven learned about
Star Wars no [ __ ] yeah
from Angry Birds Star Wars what yeah
that's crazy
that's so weird I am in this sweater
they'll never find it never find me rule
upon said crotch in it yeah exactly yeah
we don't know what do you like when his
head looked like what he was wearing
that sweater
Nick Phantom says I keep thinking
there's a cat whenever his bells ring
your cat wears reindeer bells this is
what reindeer sounds like that cats
crazy oh yeah oh yeah you can get in
vehicles and stuff that's awesome yeah I
can fly all over this yeah I know I
guess yeah thinking I can yeah you must
be able to get into an x-wing if you saw
one or maybe not I mean that's oh nice
well done hey there we go honor guard
Leia
Vader's nearby Oh
I will say one cool thing and I finished
the floor one cool thing about this game
that you kind of don't see in the movies
is how powerful like the heroes are you
know what I'm saying like like you don't
see because in the movies it's like you
kind of just have like Luke fighting
Vader and all this stuff you know like
that's pretty powerful yeah and what's
Mikey that's good it's great we're doing
that we're doing oh my god there's Vader
but the thing is like you don't you
don't kind of you kind of don't see how
powerful they are compared to other
people see he's just so you can't stop
him like and this it's really cool
because ah you'll see Vader on the
battlefield like we just did in your
life there's no way I could you just
flyer just swipes through like 20 dudes
just like really fader Dylan the Mad
King I was born on Star Wars what does
that mean mark I'd be GA yeah she's
wearing a doctor whose sweater yes oh my
god get Vader get Bader Oh No if I could
drive Oh God in a net by the way and
that's not gonna stop that not gonna
stop us speeder particularly that was
absurd a net oh this little cloth net
destroyed my speeder how are you in real
life it driving it's making me scared
yes that's right it's all good activated
right before we died right before we
died but like why is that do you think
why are you such a bad driver well okay
I'm good at driving in Borderlands but
I'm really bad at driving in Grand Theft
I but that's fun terrible driving guys
let's go off-roading and
dance on top of my car all the time oh
you ghost ride the whip yeah nice
ghost ride the whip it's a game I turned
myself off the Hollywood sign killed
myself whoa
that's a great way to cure I know I was
like you know what I've always wanted to
do this living out your suicidal
fantasies agreed that sounds great hey G
Jay King 78 what's up
somebody said Michele's wearing a doctor
whose sweater blaze wearing a doctor who
is that that's great
best joke of the day let me see
Borderlands on Monday melee all right
we'll play a boil and absolutely if
you're just joining us were here with
Michelle Moore oh good find her geek and
sundry every Monday including right
after this stream where they're giving
away a valve key which is all valve
games past present and future amazing
unbelievable
so what half-life 3 comes out you will
get that you wanna have a valve key
which is crazy yes we did it
victory it was all us 16th place very
laughs that's true we weren't but you
know proud of wait how did oh I wonder
how did how did big fat what was it too
fat to die to die
oh they were the last I love it I love
GTA 5 but somebody said they finished it
in two days how meth probably they're
probably just a lot of meth no they
finished GTA 5 in two days it's like The
Shining it's like you've always played
GT you'll never stop exactly you've
always played it let's play let's play
the jaw the jaw ku for it cuz it's
really fun it came out today if you're
free if you pre-ordered it came out
today
absolutely Dillon the Mad King let's
have a fallout 4 stream I've been
streaming it on my personal twitch on
Aaron Blair's if you want to do that
that's been really I've watched you a
few that's been yeah that's been really
fun
I thought that file that looks fun yeah
make it not boring exactly sometimes
like sometimes the really big sort of
that kind of world
yeah it does it does my room and I feel
the same like yeah I never really loved
Skyrim for that yeah absolutely
um I like to have mission-based and very
you know yeah adventure like I like like
I'm charted I've just started playing oh
god of War's my favorite games we've got
somewhere god awards the first game that
to me that I played that had that flow
combat system totally which is obviously
Batman doesn't Batman amazing Mad Max
was actually great too it was fun
because they had this vehicle combat
which is home then you get out of the
vehicle it's like that um but yeah but
yeah I love those guys me I do get up
that is it's when you say that because I
Skyrim and fallout I get obsessed with
in vignettes exactly I'm like oh this
and it all it does weirdly your world
becomes a lot about weight and how much
you're carrying and what you're doing
and where you're equipping yeah that's
very weird yeah because in my real life
I am not obviously anal at all about
anything but look at how cool is this
look at this this is awesome this
apparently is where of course when you
start look at this is this this huge
crazy graveyard of ships exactly wow
that's a super-fun so we're just
supposed to kill we're supposed to
capture points
today by robbing our uh chat boy jumps
that's quite a name
ah my twisting just my regular name
Aaron Blair
Lulla fought us on layers of fear on my
notes if you played layers of fear yeah
it's a steam game where it's kind of
like not amnesia is a little amnesia ask
but you're a painter and you've gone and
yet you have basically means you're
trying to figure out what's going on and
you kind of murder me hole to make your
paintings it's very cool it's very
creepy as this horror game junghwa vault
hey greetings from germany hail but
shotgun yeah
oh man it's awesome I mean are you a you
big horror game fan oh no I did know
that I forgot yes
wait one more movie what were you in
what were you in Oh slaughterhouse at
the rising star I love oh there we go
wait how did you get injured I well it
was after we were done filming but I
fell off a theorem on to my head whoa
people don't know it err I'm assuming
you step on it shoots you like so you
fly using like car explosions like I'm
cool I can do my own stunts I have
terrible knees I think it would just
like shoot my knee off my leg terrible I
love it there we go
your bread and butter it's your bread
and butter what what's a good horror
movie you've seen recently GRU cuz
there's kind of been like there's been
this revival aboard you know with like
these guys like ty West and stuff I've
been watching actually which is I find
terrifying awesome David Tennant is the
bad guy amazing dr. hood yeah exactly
right he's so good I'm it seen yet it
really shows you what Stockholm Syndrome
would be like in the way mind control
but it's just really very subtle subtle
way he kind of gets people because
whatever he says people have to follow
right it's like when I wear this sweater
it's basically I'm the purple man when I
wear this whatever you know the power
exact know the power but a terrible one
of the reasons it also works so well is
I think that's so many of us see David
Tennant over the years and like just
fell in love with him totally because of
the doctor yeah and then you see him as
this and he's boy telling you what to do
and commanding people and you're like do
terrible thing I mean he's brought guys
along I mean you think about Rory or
something yeah that's sure yeah like
yeah like you said guys come on the
TARDIS and hang out totally and he's
he's truck yeah he's charming his own
way I kind of like that kind of that
casting of David Tennant oh yeah it does
kind of even play with him being Doctor
Who kind of the cultural knowledge I
love a broadchurch cuz I was excited
about Roger just 400 Robin are
Rob are such a good name yeah amazing
but broadchurch because David Tennant's
and that also yes I watched it the
American version of the BBC version I
was watching that one and I was like I
don't know I need to get further in yeah
but so I started watching Jessica Jones
it was just like whoa jeez I mean that's
intense
I think it's just because we have our
own attachment to him yeah yeah totally
yeah I love I find it scary because of
that and I'm categorizing it as horror
because of that interesting it's like I
think it's like a logical horror
psychological so it's very scary
awesome I yeah I do love yeah when they
play like with like the cultural the
knowledge of like the actor in the
culture like that's one of the reasons
why I like Birdman really that's Michael
Keaton everyone knows me Batman right
and so and he's playing kind of a
similar character good so it's so
healthy yet so deadly
you know this cultural knowledge of
Michael Keaton is Batman same thing I
was like Matt LeBlanc and episodes you
know same thing with like what Ricky
Gervais stood with extras and how he had
like even killing these people oh I know
they come in kind of playing versions in
themselves I really that's one of my
favorite games the old ladies with the
butt of the gun just smacking so funny
which by the way can't wait for
Zoolander to super excited yeah I'm
gonna try to get my boyfriend to dress
up again with Zoolander oh my god
if how does he lose steal good we have
you ever seen it jus later have you met
my boyfriend Mike and his I met him but
I haven't seen his dude
haven't you ever people stop him in the
street and think that he's Zoolander not
Ben Stiller remind you
zoo people think he's a fictional
character like Last Action Hero
okay come off the screen people like any
lady walking in the grove or something
and people want pictures crazy and so he
does blue steel for a while I was like I
tried to convince him
should make a tumblr that's real life
zulay yeah oh my god that would be
awesome no you do a whole book she's in
advertising and he's just like now see
when I was fatter people you see that
with me in Guy Fieri cuz it was you know
my beard is a little darker the hair was
white little chubbier boom Guy Fieri my
tips Rob Neyer is killing us right now
we got nada
you know it's an ads it's an absence
I'll tell alt/option this is nothing
like battlefield what do you mean it's
exactly like battlefield because it is
battlefield
oh it's Battlefront sorry something
about it I don't know yo battlefield I'm
there I never really I never really
played battlefield but I did I do love
the massive the whole like we're just
playing with like 40 people it's awesome
Albert Jacque says Aaron can you please
play cry of fear really creepy okay
although you know I gotta say as a
horror game
don't put I'm tired of like putting fear
in the title of things you know like
whatever like f.e.a.r layers of fear cry
is the fear cry of fear you know
whatever fear and write all these things
fear fear fear terribly by the way how
bizarre Time Lord was number one yep
interesting Wow weird that's what I was
ee now things are getting crazy true
it's true well they started out creepy
with this and they've continued being
creepy but I things like that make me
feel like we're all in a giant matrix II
video game everything if you ever wonder
if like when you die you're just gonna
wait like step back like an arcade
cabinet or something you'd be like
alright I'll actually be bet it's fraud
you know like yeah exactly exactly does
make if you can live in any video game
world
ever Oh what would you live in oh that's
a great question
oh man um well not Grand Theft Auto cuz
that passion that shit's crate too hyper
cray Oh Jack yeah that's right we do
that's a good question
all right what about you do you have one
loaded up giving it I think I mean for
me Super Mario Galaxy maybe Super Mario
Galaxy but I think maybe all that all
this sounds like I was trying to eat
like boop boop but like make me crazy
that's a good question because it's so
beautiful or maybe a Lego game ooh what
about like lego dimensions as well so I
came around got Last of Us that'd be
brutal but you know fun I guess for a
while until you died which would be ten
minutes and the world of overwatch
should be pretty sweet because you have
a bunch of really cool heroes watching
after you so wait what does over one
explain what overwatch is to me Oh what
is it it's based on it's basically more
than warcraft no no no it's like it's
blizzards new IP it's their first
brand-new yes their first new IP in like
17 years good God hearthstone is like
heroes of Warcraft right yes so this is
their fair one that's a friend heroes of
the storm is still like based on all
their franchises so this one is its own
and it's like 6v6
yes so it's a and then each one each one
of the heroes are from different places
in the world and it's also said on earth
which is something that blizzards never
done that's Chloe isn't like fantasy
years I buy right you know like in now
it's set on earth then here's all these
heroes and they're releasing more and
more about the story through through
animation through comic books awesome
instead of doing story mode in the game
that's awesome I just play through and
it's really fun and what's cool is that
you can just switch heroes every time
like if you die or if you decide like
you know what we need more healers or
like let's go all tanks all of us you
just all be like all win
or all mercies are all well yeah it's
really fun that's awesome that sounds
incredible it's it's a super fun game
and I'm glad and it's gonna be on Xbox
one and ps4 too
I couldn't be happier that like nerds
have become ascendant because it's like
you know like growing up it was Whitney
like I'm from Michigan where you from me
from knees can't watch it gonna stay up
CPR
okay that was I was good I knew it was
someone all the time I knew it's a place
kind of a cold and whatever yeah um but
north yeah and it's like being like it's
Spokane or being like in in in Michigan
in Ann Arbor it's kind of like you're by
yourself and it's kind of before the
internet was really a big yeah you're
kind of go like I was in my basement
yeah right there's no one like you me or
anything and you're kind of like oh and
then but now it's very accepted and very
cool to be and it's awesome because we
get to play Star Wars or we get to play
over on all these all these awesome
games together together it's like we've
created this awesome world people say
anything cartoon like really the
Scarecrow for what world they want to
live it oh yeah what world would you
guys want to live in do you live in
anywhere it's just like it's like a hat
I have I have this silly show on Polaris
I'm the sling Network Alaris and it's
all about just asking really dumb
questions about video games and so like
hey there are no dumb questions about
they're really they're really good ones
like what's the sexiest text Tetris
piece ha ha ha which one I mean the
obvious would be the thing I say the L
because you're like because it's just
like the boring straight piece but it's
got a little bit of weirdness to it it
kind of keeps kind of keeps you guessing
the zigzag what you say hold on what's
your favorite McNugget shape let's get
to some serious questions yes there's
the boots the boot the diamonds yeah the
boot the diamond the like circle and
then what's the other one
the boot diamond circle let me think
back to my big nugget no God google it
google it
I think the Diamonds good because you
can kind of keep eating every end to
keep making it a smaller diamond that's
true although I like the boot here's why
I like the boot I'm passionate about I'm
getting me I can make that gate
I like the boot because all right
because it's perfectly I don't know if
they did this on purpose I still hold on
but the the foot part
the foot part what's the other shape
what's the other with all a ball wait
there's a ball boot of the bell Bell
boot oh the bone the bone is the one I
didn't think of because the boot if you
put it in the sauce perfectly matches I
know they are yes oh my god what I still
would eat McNuggets even if they talk I
don't care I love them I love them I
don't owe you I'm out for talking food
like the M&Ms like that [ __ ] freaks me
out
can I see the Yahoo the Taco Bell emoji
game No what's this boy Taco Bell by the
way is the bomb on Instagram they're
killing it so my boyfriend works at an
ad firm called Deutsch and they they do
the Taco Bell account right love it much
about talk about can't know too much
that's very true actually but they came
up with this fun emoji game where you
put at Taco Bell and in honor of the new
taco emoji you can put any other emoji
and Taco Bell will send you a gift
once at Taco Bell and then you put the
emoji and then it's like you put a nerd
face no way I put Taco Bell in a video
game and had like it was like the old
wireframe Star Wars game actually yeah
and it has like a taco inside of a
goal and it's all like 8-bit and cute
and cool on out damn it
that's awesome thing that's really silly
I love that that's great I love it she
whenever it was like one of the most
brilliant usages of emoji that I've seen
first sure like absolutely like it's
awesome I love this self-aware like how
brands are getting self-aware now it
becomes fun it's a just like eat this
they like oh Jesus look at these look at
this by the way taco
okay what what other emojis look at the
huge ships going down in flames dope
it's great there's like crazy I love it
like this is beautiful this is great oh
boy are you a felon you can pick oh man
this is great
let's see Taco Bell what homeland note
what about menorah what about the
menorah oh yeah
do we tweet it out now what it is do it
and tweet it out you did it
followed by the way Michelle [ __ ] on
the old Twitter one L know
and now they're gonna alright well now
we're waiting for talk about no now we
go to talk about oh there we go oh my
god what did it do they did it back they
did I don't know it was just a bunch it
looks like a bunch of tacos in a way
it's a bunch of Honor isn't eight days
of tacos yes I think it's eight days of
tacos can you see this that's what they
did and they did it like immediately Wow
well done Taco Bell on point was like a
taco on like a chair like it like yeah I
should know oh the yeah
but Conan Conan and Crick Conan took one
of our IT guy Chris Hayes who loves Taco
Bell to talk about headquarters to have
in the kitchen to make his perfect food
is perfect talk about food he's dreamed
yeah he's dream talk yeah hit him with a
link but really it was great and they
brought back a bunch of Taco Bell swag
so I got like a hat like a watch oh
Jesus yeah I know we're just enjoying
talk about it come it mine came up with
like like a trading card little soldier
with chili foul that was a great episode
oh they haven't the avicad Avril I think
dolly said I think that was one of our
one of the things he made did he name it
yeah
oh the Oh taco yeah there's like a
potato in a in a taco shell Taco Bell
let's talk about taste like Dylan the
Mad King ooh all right
it tastes like it tastes like the first
time you see your true love's face you
know it feels it tastes like that tastes
like the laughter of children you know
it tastes like it tastes like sunlight
reflecting off of a dappled sunlight off
of water you know what I'm saying it
tastes like it tastes like it tastes
better than Pizza exactly we do cheese
in a taco yeah oh geez I'm not on it not
on a pizza wow that's interesting what
about in a calzone in a walk-in account
[ __ ] calzones now those things are the
word [ __ ] calzones Michele Mauro 250 all
right you know what you need those
things you got the best quote of the
year in at the very end of the year she
did it [ __ ] what's wrong with the cows
Oh calzone are the worst it's like a hot
words really it's not the worst it's
like an Italian burrito it's like an
Italian burrito see what kind of oh no
look at the way it's like shapes - it's
just like what do you mean it's shaped
just like a hot pocket or like I guess
I'm not sweetening the deal with my hot
pocket dog yeah yeah that in this
sweater I just get kicked off I just get
blocked and reported in photo V just a
media block and report exactly Oh Nick
phantoms I don't like talk about to be
honest don't like it get off the street
you know one thing is they do have they
do have del Taco in LA dub do they tell
talk in Spokane is that they did okay
they didn't have that on the east coast
or in the Midwest so I came to LA and
I'm like what's Del Taco del Taco you
can get tacos and like Burgers and Fries
yeah and stuff and they also have 39
cent tacos which is both an
advertisement and a warning I kind of
feel like you know it's like hey we made
this we're selling these for 39 cents so
it took less than 39 cents to make this
taco because they're not gonna lose
money on Taco Bell tacos it's like the
guy who created it or whatever was his
name del you only ask to other people in
his family like his brothers oh that's
awesome sister or something in Del Taco
Weezer does only Arby's what's wrong
with you Arby's is delicious what's your
what's your stance on Arby's is cool
that's cool totally fine
exactly hey Tim attacker eat
shady says they've old out pot old El
Paso in in in the UK not talked about
interesting talking about these to get
on the game expand their brand globally
stop stop this I'm worried about
emoticons and stuff and get your brand
out there and your other a year since I
knew I others should we talk about
poutine from Canada actually I have you
know what I've had I have had a
delicious fish taco with cabbage in it
like that's the thing is like la has all
these like how can I get killed but it
shouldn't the Machine get killed first
it should it should that's a flaw that's
a fly that's a gameplay I [ __ ] that's
like armor that's like ghosts and
goblins when you get hit one yeah yes
exactly be like that's here and it
should also be underwear please
oh god really I would probably cry oh I
do love in this game to how the
attention to detail where the guys over
dramatically fall like in the first like
four or five in six movies like Rashi
Dom high says Tom Hortons is amazing I'm
not a big pastry guy so I don't do Tim
Hortons demorgan's it's like a pastry
it's kind of like dunkey doughnuts are
like a it's like kind of a doughnut
eShop but classy so you can get you can
get your bear claws there you can get
your cinnamon buns is a big Tim Hortons
thing listen the sound of no Tara not
beats a place of my college had a
deep-fried calzones come that begs is my
new personal name for myself hey fat hey
fat bags what are we eating today salad
good you just you just spoke my true
name
I didn't realize yes I want tighty
whities for Christmas that's a home with
a whopper right on the front
oh that would be great somebody send me
those Burger King get on that Burger
King
joy joy says tip tip horns is not
upper-class play well it's upper class
for me so I guess that means I'm super
too logical I gotta say yeah one of my
favorite things about the emergence he's
doing you know you're just gonna have so
many ridiculous things stars fat bags
that is that's gonna be my bark it up
420 spark it up really killing it I know
it's gonna be even better when it's in
the Olympics spark it up for 20 with the
Olympic medal it's William it's only a
matter of time till eSports it's the
Olympics you gotta be excited about that
you play you have your own play
competitively I one time did yeah and
how did it go
we won yes were you nervous I was
actually there was a bunch of people
watching online like yes oh my god
that's crazy we had a live audience
that's awesome
and I've never played competitively live
at least what something surprised you
about playing competitively that you
weren't expected that I only died once
oh wow what I'm Raymond laning with a
pro gamer against a pro gamer who's
excellent well done that's awesome
I think that and I think to like people
have sort of like lower expectations
because they're like oh great thing our
team is called low expectation that's
why you where you want to be though
competitively I always I always love
like the best thing someone can do is to
underestimate right which is hard cuz
I'm really bad obviously so it's very
hard to underestimate me but if you can
do it I'll surprise so much more fun
exactly
have I tried aviation burger no I
haven't I don't know oh man
Akron well done hack rim although I was
Isaac I think people are moving more net
and moving more towards using their real
names now handles yeah you know like
it's social media I feel like that's
happening oh good I'm right in the
crotch
tree - right in the crotch that's
somebody's real name that's somebody's
real name from the from the north the
East Hampton's wild zeroes the famous
old money wild zero exactly yes we did
oh my god I love it oh my god well I
think that'll do it for today
Michelle Morel thank you so much laughs
O'Malley you bastard is it not gonna
catch Michelle on a geek asunder stream
which is starting when I at 1:30 so 1:30
go over to geek and sundry's channel you
can win a valve key give it away today
which is very exciting inches all valve
games past present and future so
half-life 3 you will get if it ever
comes out just like dr. Dre's detox
album if it ever comes out that's good
it that's gonna be the soundtrack for
for half-life 3 fantastic thank you guys
for joining us followed by the way
Michelle Morel at everything twitter at
facebook facebook it's michelle moral
officials official Instagram Facebook
he's awesome as if you already are
that's right happy show more with one L
remember I'll come to your house your
mom is great at naming people exactly ah
that'll go great we'll see you guys next
week see you later
you